dan if you were going to deliver an
imaginary college commencement speech
for 2013 creative grads as opposed to
med school grads or law school what
would it be I would say to walk over to
the med school graduation ceremony for
the law school graduation ceremony tell
a couple jokes and befriend someone who
will be your spouse Wow okay it's it
really yeah now if it works for me yeah
you want to marry well if you want to do
this for long term and and and I mean
this you know don't marry an actress or
an actor or another director you know
that's very difficult marry someone it
was a gonna be doctor or a lawyer and
usually they're easily entertained you
know so it doesn't take much to come and
yeah you need someone to help support
you in this not small Terrace oh yeah
that's helpful yeah
but not just monetarily although I
understand that's probably 90% of the
battle I get that but also too in
temperament
because creative types tend to thrive on
instability maybe be in stable
themselves or they like the highs and
lows of the business because nothing's
ever guaranteed and the rugs always
pulled out from under unit wise money
and whereas those others seem to me a
little more grounded in reality and some
sense is that also good yes yeah no I
think I think people in other
professions tend to have a bit more even
keel they're not like project to project
driven like you know I yeah I can have
huge highs and lows within an hour and
and it gets very stressful to be a
filmmaker
there's no you don't know what's around
the corner so yes being married or a
relationship with someone that's in a
more stable situation emotionally and
financially all other ways it's probably
a good idea yeah I know a lot of
creative types don't like to show up at
the same place every day and I get that
so why don't you sell insurance or cars
or widgets or what is it about a long
time ago going back to college and then
you know finally taking those classes it
was it UCLA I don't know I mean that's a
longer question our longer answer to a
shorter question why I don't know I'd
like it I like movies I guess I don't
see very many but I from what I hear
they're nice and I think for me I think
it's in making movies is a great sort of
mix of artistic and creative side but
also they're very practical and
quantitative side and it's one of the
few fields and I think kind of mixes
them nicely I think architecture is
probably another one that does that um
Frank ury
yeah so yeah I I think that's what
appeals to me about it why not so I'm
not very good at anything else I don't
know if I'm good at this but someone
lets me do it I guess yeah why not do it
as a side project on the weekends why
did you make this
it basically is a side yeah I mean my
day job is running kids to school so
making movies is the side project yeah
no I certainly don't make money on it I
mean we've made more money renting out
our house as a location than we have for
me directing ever but in terms of the
culmination of your your career and what
you're known for I mean you've done
that's very generous of you by the way
to say I have a
well you have you have a numerous
creative things you've been a part of
whether it's slam dance whether it's the
book you know you've chosen that and and
you're bright enough to know that you
know nothing's ever promised but
obviously you've realized that the other
wasn't an alternative for you and I'm
just curious for other people that are
creative that or maybe pressured by
family or friends or their peers to go
out and follow one set path and then
choosing something that's probably a lot
more fun but is very unstable but
knowing that that's what they want to
get up and do every day when did you
come to peace with that inside yourself
I'm still working on that and that's
yeah that's but I think that's part of
what I mean this gets into the whole
issue of transmedia you know dressing up
in dresses and making movies or whatever
transmedia means to different people but
the idea that you come up with you don't
worry about the medium you know maybe
it's a movie maybe it's a book maybe
it's a internet tell them but you have
an idea a route of an idea or a
character or a style a filmmaker or
acting or whatever it is you do and just
kind of pursue that as far as it goes
and then take that dead horse and beat
it some more you know and then milk it a
little bit after that get a taxidermist
yeah exactly and and I mean I you know
that's certainly what happened with the
Eisenstaedt project where that was
started as a started as a promo for a
video game which morphed into a spec car
commercial which turned into a short
film which turned into a short pilot
which turned into a written pilot which
turned into a TV pitch which turned into
an Internet hoax which we thought was
maybe going to be a documentary and then
it wound up turning into a book deal
which we thought was going to go back to
TV and now it may still could be a
documentary or a narrative feature I
mean we don't know but that's kind of a
perfect example
it's an idea that had legs and we didn't
know where those legs are gonna run but
they ran somewhere you know so and you
know it's a similar thing with open
house you know it was a straightforward
comedy script turned into musical
feature turned into a whole Oscar
campaign which is a whole other story
that you don't have room on your camera
for you know but which led me to
Broadway I never thought I would be
having Broadway meetings I don't I've
never seen a Broadway show in my life
you know
but you just go you know you just follow
you know and you just have to have faith
in your own ability to at some point
later figure out a way to turn that
thing into something else so a little
bit of faith and balls so going back to
the commencement speech aside from
marrying well or someone with an
opposite sort of goal that maybe is more
of a set path it sounds like always be
working on something or am I not putting
words but yeah always be working on
something that sounds good yeah I should
listen to that morning yeah it helps I
mean unfortunately I'm not very good at
I'm not a good example of someone who
has multiple balls in the air at the
same time like the Eisenstaedt thing in
between us I was sort of a rare instance
where I did that and it worked out and
at the end of the day they both got made
you know what in one form or another but
it is good advice yeah I would tell
other people to do that and if you're
good at that
you should do that and have three
scripts and two plays and an internet
series all going at the same time but so
if you can do that you are better off
yeah I'm more of a take one thing and
milk it milk the dead horse till it's
stuffed on the wall for better for worse
sometimes that works out in sometimes it
doesn't
you